lange war sie angekündigt nun hat sie
offenbar endlich begonnen die
ukrainische gegen offensive im süden des
landes wir wollen uns von heute morgen
bilder ansehen die erst mal optisch
nicht so viel hergeben aber man hört es
vielleicht im hintergrund hier sind
schüsse zu hören und das ist aus hessen
statt also aus der stadt die seit dem 25
februar von russischen truppen schon
besetzt wurde und seitdem auch
kontrolliert wird dort haben heute
morgen sind die menschen aufgewacht
nicht zu artillerie vorher nicht zu
irgendwelchen raketeneinschlägen weit
entfernt sondern man hört man sieht auch
diesen diesen brauch man hört diese
diese schüsse im hintergrund schüsse die
man eben nur hört wenn ganz in der nähe
gekämpft wird dort haben die russischen
besatzer mittlerweile gesagt ja man
wirkliche samt saboteure heute morgen
jagen und aus ukrainischen quellen haben
wir erfahren dass hier ein weiterer
kollaborateur der russische
besatzungsarmee geben heute morgen
getötet wurde wichtig die ukrainische
armee scheint noch nicht in person
selbst zu sein aber sie hat offenbar
schläferzellen dort aktiviert heute
morgen die eben anfangen hier in der
stadt selbst aktiv zu werden hier unten
sehen wir auch leute die wissen
überhaupt nicht was sie machen sollen
fahren sie rad zur arbeit oder gehen sie
wieder nach hause sie hören die schüsse
sind also nicht genau was los ist wir
wollen ist das ganze mal auf der karte
ansehen über was wir denn überhaupt
sprechen dass also die ukraine und hier
unten haben wir die region herrschen wir
können die einmal erstmal markieren um
zu sehen wie groß die dann ist das ist
die regierung und ganz gut so jetzt
haben ist das ist die region carson
einmal nördlich der krim und ebenda
rechts der isar und donau setzt ist das
gesamte rote gebiet also 95 prozent der
region so etwa und nach dem was wir
erfahren haben gibt es die ukrainische
gegenoffensive aus drei richtungen
einmal richtung nikolajew ganz in
richtung carson staatskasse nämlich die
stadt einmal über den in görlitz ein
kleiner fluss hierüber und einmal aus
richtung wie hier im norden das heißt
wir haben eine breit angelegte
ukrainische gegenoffensive hier auf 150
kilometer mit schwerpunkten natürlich
und damit diese gegenoffensive gelingt
haben die ukrainer in den letzten wochen
immer wieder die beiden entscheidenden
brücken bei personen und nova charakter
bombardiert mit diesen amerikanischen
waffen mit dieser hien ass oder heimers
waffen dort können die russen schon seit
wochen keinen nachschub mehr liefern
müssen sich auf kleine fähren beziehen
also die sie selbst gebaut haben auch
die wurden heute morgen nochmal
bombardiert und die ukraine hoffen also
nicht die gesamte region zu eroberten
aber erst ein mal eben den nördlichen
teil also den teil nördlich der hre
hätten apple wir sehen das teilt hier
die region in der hälfte und dort glaubt
die ukrainische armee hat sie die
strategisch günstigste position
überhaupt um eine gegenoffensive zu
starten indem man eben die rosen vom
nachschub abschneiden in vergleichen
gleichzeitig jetzt nicht mehr ermöglicht
dort abzuhauen es sei denn sie schwimmen
das problem ist natürlich wenn man dort
erst mal ist dann haben die russen die
starke front da haben die russen den er
diesen einen der breitesten flüssen
europas der ihnen hilft und der eben
dafür sorgt dass sie nicht weiter dass
die ukraine dort nicht weiter vordringen
können nichtsdestotrotz allein dieser
bereich da oben das wäre ein riesiger
gewinn wenn die ukraine ihn
zurückerobern
wir gucken uns das ganze mal an es gab
gestern ein erstes foto es gibt eine
nachrichtensperre muss man sagen ein
erstes foto wo die ukraine gezeigt haben
ja wir versuchen hier vorzudringen und
wir sehen hier
mehrere m 113 und zwar die
niederländische variante die also aus
den niederlanden gebracht wurde diese
schnellen fahrzeuge sollen sie zusammen
mit infanterie offenbar vordringen wir
haben auch von russischer seite gehört
dass allein an einer stelle 13 panzer
und 272 aus der aus polen genutzt werden
auf jeden fall die russische armee dort
unter extrem großen druck dank dieser
ukrainischen gegenoffensive